russian troops continue intense shelling
attacks this weekend in ukraine let's
bring in south carolina congressman
ralph norman for more on military
operations and the humanitarian crisis
there he is on the house homeland
security and oversight committees
congressman first of all the the the
continuing quandary of these polish migs
uh soviet-built fighters that now belong
to poland uh that the united states
first said yeah you can you can ship
those into ukraine and then sort of
backed away
where does that stand and what do you
think about the uh the the stalemate
that the united states has left poland
in here
you know john it's unfortunate this
president
is continuing to to not give the green
light to give the ukrainians what they
need to fight it's not like we're asking
americans pilots to fight it's giving
the ukrainian
people the uh necessary protection from
the migs and why he's not letting
the mix take you know use our
uh off-ramp to get on to to fly in is is
beyond me no one can understand why he's
doing that
i want to play for you something that
democratic senator
dick durbin the majority whip had to say
about all of this and i'll get your
thoughts afterwards listen
we're asking for one third of the polish
air force
to be sent into ukraine the people of
poland of course want to make certain
that they're safe there are other ways
for us to provide surface-to-air
missiles and air defenses that will keep
the russians at bay in terms of their
aerial attack
i think there are ways to do that that
are consistent with the nato alliance
and would not jeopardize expanding this
into world war iii or even worse well of
course the people of poland want to know
that they are safe but the people of
poland are also covered under the nato
treaty an attack on poland would bring
the fire of nato
down on the russians or the belarusians
or anybody else who staged such an
attack so why not go ahead and send the
migs over
well this president sent into sending
the message to the whole world
that he just inept he's not going to do
it and time is running out you look at
uh what's happening to the cities all
across the ukraine uh now 80 of the
towns are torn up apart the time is
running out he's going to miss the
opportunity if he doesn't give the green
light to it but i don't think he is and
he has given no indication that he'll
that he's he's going to make that call
which he should make
yeah the russians have said mario paul
on the coast has something like six
hours to surrender
uh i don't know what happens if they
don't and there's no indication from the
ukrainians that they're going to but
there's very little left of mario paul
already
here's what senator uh
senator barrasso of wyoming had to say
about the president's
stature which seems to be leading from
behind listen
the president has had to be pushed and
pulled to where he is today it was
congress that brought about sanctions
that brought about
the ban on russian oil that brought
about weapons and all of this big aid
package that i voted for a week or two
ago 13 billion dollars so far the
administration has only released 1
billion of that and if as president i
think if they done more in sanctions we
might not have been in this situation if
they had done punishing sanctions before
the tanks began to roll yeah and
president biden said the sanctions were
going to prevent all of this from
happening in the first place he was
obviously wrong about that why not
release more money why not get those
anti-aircraft systems for instance into
ukraine
well john he's known about this since
april of last year he's taken no action
he slow walked even the sanctions uh the
cutting off the all from russia
everything he's doing is is as if he's
he's you know wanting ukraine to fall uh
and he's not helping himself with
letting russians uh negotiate to jcpoa
with iranians so the question is why and
you know if this isn't the case for
really taking seriously impeaching uh by
i don't know what is that we're seeing
on the on the national on the world
stage a humanitarian crisis like we've
never seen before
we saw that when zielinski spoke to
congress he showed the film of the
children getting blown up the the
innocent civilians so it's time for for
this for the all of congress to come
forward and ask bind to do the right
thing and release the migs
congressman ralph norman republican from
south carolina congressman thank you
my pleasure hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else